-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
here, from New York City.
Hey, everybody.
Thank you, Roots.
Let's get to the news
and jokes.
Well, guys,
after weeks of delays,
the White House
is finally giving
President-elect Biden access
to something very important.
Watch this.
-2 1/2 weeks after Biden won,
President Trump finally
giving formal approval
for Biden to receive
the president's daily brief.
It's highly classified
information
that Biden will need.
-That's right,
the president-elect
is finally
receiving Trump's daily brief.
Today, Biden was like,
"Okay, gotcha. That's right.
Okay, this is a
'Marmaduke' cartoon.
So, is this --"
[ Laughter ]
It's okay, Trump doesn't need
the daily brief anymore.
He gets all his intelligence
from Randy Quaid's tweets.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks to Trump's daily brief,
Biden will now be well-versed
in foreign and domestic threats
and who got eliminated
on "The Bachelorette."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, it does turn out
that the brief they give Biden
is a little different than
the one they give Trump.
I'll show you what I mean.
For instance,
Biden's brief says,
"Iran building nuclear arsenal."
While Trump's brief says,
"Iran make big fireworks
that go boom-boom."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow.
Next up, Biden's brief says,
"Norway experiencing
harsh climate change."
While Trump's says,
"Soon Olaf will be a puddle."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Biden's brief says,
"Canada extends border
restrictions with U.S."
While Trump's says, "Americans
betrayed by Beliebers."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just a little different.
Even though the transition has
already begun, Rudy Giuliani
is still trying to overturn
the election.
Today he talked about
voter fraud at an event
in Gettysburg, Pennsylvania.
People were pumped about
the event.
Not to hear Rudy's speech,
just to see
what's gonna leak
out of his head.
It's almost Thanksgiving,
I hope it's gravy!
[ Laughter ]
But Rudy was smart this time.
First he dyed his hair,
then he applied a coat
of Thompson's WaterSeal
over it.
Very smart.
And this is very interesting.
Trump was also supposed to be
in Gettysburg,
but he cancelled
at the last minute
because of COVID concerns.
-Hmm? What?
-That's great. Trump was like,
"It's not safe to be there
in person, so, Rudy, you go."
"Okay."
Trump ended up appearing over
speakerphone in Gettysburg,
and he actually delivered
a speech inspired by
Abraham Lincoln's
famous address.
Here, check it out.
-Four seasons and seven
total landscapings ago,
the liberal media brought forth
on this consonant,
a news so fake,
conceived by the haters
and losers,
can you believe it, folks,
and dedicated to the
preposition that every person,
woman, man, camera,
TV was created equal.
-Okay, I got it.
That's it.
[ Applause ]
Speaking of the President,
today he decided to pardon
his former National Security
Adviser, Michael Flynn.
He announced it via tweet.
He wrote, "It is my great honor
to announce that
General Michael T. Flynn has
been granted a full pardon."
On one hand,
Flynn is thrilled.
On the other, he's like, "You
pardoned the turkey before me?"
[ Laughter ]
When people heard the name
Michael Flynn, they were like,
"Wow, they brought back
a character from season one
for the finale.
[ Laughter ]
Cool!"
[ Applause ]
That's how you do it.
Seriously, there's a name
from the past.
Even Michael Flynn was like,
"Damn, I totally forgot
about Michael Flynn."
[ Laughter ]
Here's some news about
the pandemic.
It looks like the CDC is
changing its recommendation
for how long you should
quarantine.
Listen to this.
-The CDC is reportedly set
to shorten its quarantine
recommendation.
It could go from the current
14 days to between 7 and 10 days
for those who might have been
exposed to the virus.
-Yep, this isn't based
on science.
It's just that there's nothing
left to binge on Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
We already watched
the chess show.
[ Laughter ]
We're good.
Oh, if you're doing
some cooking tomorrow,
you better listen to this.
A popular kitchen appliance
is being recalled.
Take a look.
-Sunbeam is voluntarily
recalling
nearly a million crock pot
six-quart multicookers.
The company says the cookers
can pressurize
when the lid is not
fully locked,
and that creates a burn hazard.
-Anybody who watches
"This Is Us" was like,
"A little late!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, people knew
something was up
when the only button on the
crock pot was, "Good luck."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, did you see this?
There's a live action movie
about "Clifford the Big Red Dog"
coming out.
And today we got our first
glimpse of Clifford.
But some people are complaining
about how he looks.
Let's take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-Wait!
[ Laughs ]
-Clifford looks like
a soccer mom's teeth
after a pitcher of sangria.
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, people were
expecting Clifford to be
Heinz ketchup red, and what they
got was Hunt's catsup.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, check this out.
A woman in Minnesota put some
old pears in her backyard,
and I guess they were --
they got fermented,
because look what happened
when a squirrel ate one.
-This squirrel out in Minnesota
accidentally got drunk
when he ate a fermented pear.
The homeowner says that she
threw out some pears
that she found at the
bottom of her fridge.
The squirrel got into the pears.
Luckily, he was fine,
walked it off and came back in
the morning, was ready for more.
[ Laughter ]
-That's going to be everyone
on their Thanksgiving Zoom
tomorrow.